stuffed owls dressed like hipsters are
Rebecca sailors thing she spends five
hours sewing and decorating each one by
hand
sailor sells them for $50 apiece on Etsy
the online marketplace with more than 1
million shops for handmade products Etsy
was the perfect platform for me they
were doing their part to gain customers
and elevate the experience of handmade
that is she says until Etsy became more
corporate they did make some changes
which caused a weird shift in the
ecosystem 16 months ago Etsy allowed
sellers to use manufacturers to produce
on mass the goal was to help sellers
grow their businesses while Etsy built
greater scale Sailor sales have slipped
15% since then the new policy has made
it harder for consumers to find her
pillows and compete on price so why not
just use a manufacturer to compete Etsy
sellers they have this extreme emotional
connection to their piece and they want
the public at large to feel the same way
which they do I'm sure in many ways but
at the end of the day it is a business
Etsy was founded a decade ago by Rob
Kalin and two friends the idea gained
traction with other artisans and caught
the attention of big-name venture
capitalists such as accel partners and
Union Square Ventures over time though
success bred conflict and Kalyn rejected
any stray from the company's core values
and left in 2011 now sources say the
company is preparing for a 300 million
dollar IPO the new policies could help
it look more attractive to Wall Street
Etsy charges 20 cents for each listing
and three point five percent commission
from each sale the more transactions the
better Etsy declined to comment on the
policy changes in the IPO Kailyn did not
respond to requests seeking comment but
these changes are common in the lead up
to a public offering even if it means
offending some customers you know
companies need to evolve those that
don't risk being left behind in a world
around them and when they tap out their
market I think the trick is to do it in
a gradual way or way that doesn't offend
your original base as if a company moves
too quickly it can have negative impact
on the current customer base and that of
course shows up in terms of revenues and
margins and all of those things at an
Etsy team meetup in San Francisco
sellers have mixed reactions to the IPO
some say these changes are just the
price you pay for being part of a larger
ecosystem but Rick Kitagawa left the
site when the policy changes were
announced for a site that kind of clings
to really empower crafters I didn't
really feel that it was actually doing
that and yet some see Etsy's IPO as an
opportunity they've started a campaign
to raise 1.5 million and build a stake
in the IPO those used to expressing
themselves through art are starting to
do so with their wallets